now the zodiacs are pretty fascinating
organization within hunt hunter I mean
you have your cat boy rat boy track and
Dude chicken chick and of course the
most unfortunate zodiac sign being the
deadbeat dad who was only ever taught
his son one very important lesson which
is obviously to subscribe to the new
ultra view for regular hunt under
content uploaded straight into your
YouTube feed hello and welcome to the
new Walter vo source for everything
anime and manga and today I would like
to present a discussion surrounding the
zodiacs of one Tonto and quite
specifically we aren't going to be
ranking them now how are we going to
achieve this well we ranking them by
power intelligence prestige no none of
that because in this case we are going
to go with a much easier metric to
generate which is straight-up popularity
so while ago on this channel I put up a
straw poll and I asked you all to vote
for your favorite member of the original
set of zodiacs I didn't include the two
Newell members because I didn't think
would be particularly fair you know
given who they are but at the same time
I guess you could say the same thing
about the older members doesn't matter
at the time of this recording this poll
has received just under three thousand
seven hundred votes which is amazing I
think it gives us a nice snapshot of the
hunt under community or at the very
least the hunt under fans who watch this
channel so we're going to go through all
of them from least popular to most
popular and of course I will be adding
my own thoughts along the way so with
that out of the way let's commence with
the ever unfortunate 12th and last place
who is Sancho having received a total of
21 votes yes 21 votes out of you know
almost 4,000 or guy but in any case
Sasha represents the horse member of the
zodiacs although I don't know by
appearance alone you could really
potentially mistake him for being the
rat member until you meet parastone
anyway and then you see there that's a
definite rat I think that Sancho ends up
being quite forgettable though because
his design is actually more on the
understated side of the zodiac scale you
know we were introduced to this gigantic
group of colorful characters of all
shapes and sizes and then here's this
relatively normal guy with some muted
colors and his only real distinguishing
feature is his face I just don't think
that he's that well equipped to stand
out at the moment which may change if we
get to know more about him but right now
all I can say is that he is a double
star problem hunter which is kind of
fascinating actually I have no idea what
a problem hunter ears or does but I'm
picturing a man who goes around solving
various deadlines and puzzles or
something along those lines maybe like a
hunter hunter equivalent to show our
combs where they are a horse face so
it's a shame to see you this far down
the list but I guess
someone had to come in at last place
moving into 11th place now we have saw
you with 24 votes and wow this was a bit
of a surprise to me because I don't
think I would personally rank sigh you
this slow but to be fair I am quite
partial to his design I really like the
whole Sun we'll call in the inspiration
which makes all the sense in the world
because he does of course represent the
monkey position but I think what shocks
me most here is that SIA was actually
far more of a relevant character than
most of the zodiacs have been in the
story thus far and without spoiling
anything he does become something of a
plot point in the manga and I guess that
ends up adding quite a lot of interest
to him for me personally because now
whenever he turns up I am paying extra
attention to him rather than just going
oh is OD ACK but clearly the rest of you
don't necessarily feel the same way and
that is fine there are plenty about the
Magnificent figures to choose from
amongst this cohort one of which would
be 10th place ginto who I would go so
far as to say is the most visually
distinct member of the zodiacs although
admittedly his design can be a bit of a
loved it or hated situation like for
example when I was a mobi teenager I
would have hated a character like this
because I just wanted everyone to look
cool at all times however over time I
have actually developed quite a strong
appreciation for the weirder character
designs so much so that I don't think I
would have had to into this fawn down on
my personal ranking actually quite like
that toga she chose to be very bold with
this guy going full-on hairy chest all
of the Afro and why not cap things off
with the hunt hunter equivalent of a
Union Jack Bradley displayed upon
kenta's vast belly and he's also pretty
interesting because he's highly subject
to a motion of any kind be it incredible
rage or empathetic tears so yeah a
pretty intriguing guy but I can
understand why many of you aren't quite
sold on him so let's move on to number 9
being jell with 34 votes once again out
of well over 3,000 so we definitely have
something of a low tier group forming
here gel is someone who I would
personally place close to lost though
because here's the thing when I think
about gel I don't actually think any
thoughts occur I see her face in my mind
and I have nowhere to go from there
primarily because she hasn't really done
anything in the series although to her
credit she did actually show one of her
abilities which had her transform her
arm into a snake which is cool
because it does make me wonder exactly
how she achieves this bodily
metamorphosis is pretty rare in the nen
world and usually reserved for magical
beasts like the Kirikou or even the
world God u P so there's some definite
factors going in Joan's favor here as
well as her expertise in the realm of
science and general analytical ability
but on the other
and her reserved nature does generally
push her into the background for me and
apparently for most of you as well for
number eight we have colic a botanical
hunter and a Zodiac you rather obviously
represents the chicken you know really
makes you wonder which came first was
the character named cluck and then
granted the chicken role or was she
given the chicken role and then did she
change her name to cluck the classic
chicken and the clock paradox there but
in addition to her avian fiercest that a
cluck stands out to me because she has
more extroverted personality I think
that always helps in huge group dynamics
like the zodiacs so she is quite
short-tempered and eager to tell people
to shut up which is fun especially when
said anger is directed at a certain
Paris tone and in terms of nan cluck has
also shown a sliver of her abilities
which seems to involve mass pigeon
manipulation which probably makes her
something of an ultimate messenger which
even in this digital world is incredibly
useful because the pigeons can find
hunters in circumstances what
conventional communication would not
work but yeah a solid design coupled
with hints of personality and abilities
which I suppose has landed kwok here
today next up is one that really shocked
me though because in number 7 we have
bata by and I have nothing to conclude
other than people are really sleeping on
this guy I mean he is one of only three
triple star hunters that we know of and
in addition to that he is also a
terrorist hunter and has a side career
as a public prosecutor whilst he also
happens to be the most senior member of
the zodiacs representing the ever cool
dragon role and he has also been implied
to be extraordinarily powerful with one
common belief being that he was close in
ability to that of issac natural
although upon examining the official
translation admittedly all it says is
that bata bhai was close to natural
which almost certainly means that they
were more good friends than anything
else still natural doesn't really
associate himself with weak beings
because it tends to disgust him so I
think there was a lot of hype behind
bata bhai for me personally I feel like
I would have him in at least fourth
place they think but the public have
spoken and I'm afraid that he will have
to settle for seventh right now taking a
leap forward in votes now in sixth place
is Kansai who yeah I can certainly see
his popularity I mean he represents the
kind of cool bratty delinquent with
sharp teeth and a general aesthetic that
reflects his position as the tiger
zodiac very popular animal and like
clucky's also another short-tempered
member which is always fun and similarly
it does make him stand out just a little
bit more not that he necessarily needs
to
given that he is a bright yelloww
existence and will always pop in any
image and in fact you might even be able
to blame Kansai for some of the neglect
of sy you because Kansai does that whole
yellow color scheme to a much larger
degree making sy you seem you know a bit
like a budget Kansai but what I like
about him is it despite being a Zodiac
Kansai is often a bit of an ignorant
fool because he seems almost completely
unaware of the world around him and he
forgets very basic information like the
kanji for election so that generates
some genuine interest as to how he
managed to get this position although
the answer to that is more likely a case
of net or just being amused by him and
placing him amongst the zodiacs which he
did have a tendency to do but getting
serious now we have number 5 being peon
who obviously represents the other
adorable rabbit zodiac and she is
definitely the one might say token cute
female of the group but Pyong comes
equipped with some decent personality as
well as a core role in the Chairman
election arc and she was the host of
each round of voting and her presence
did make these proceedings much more
exciting than one would expect an
election to be and I also think it's
quite easy to forget that peon is also
an incredibly powerful character though
as are all the zodiacs
I mean cons I made the pretty bold
statement that they are all
significantly above the abilities of
both moral and novice so that is a
pretty grand statement but beyond has
also been ranked by Hisoka as a solid
7.7 when it comes to general power which
yes was lower than Kansai and Ginter but
way above almost every other pro hunter
present at the first round of voting
which while Hisoka may have been
disappointed is still a pretty big
endorsement of pons abilities and I
would love to see her in action properly
one day but we are now left with our
final four and miss Iceland is the first
up in that regard securing 285 votes so
I personally believe that means Iceland
is one of the most solid characters to
have come out of this particular group
and I am thrilled that he has made at
this high even if maybe I would have
bumped him up one possibly even two
positions initially he might be a bit
off-putting because he does have this
very clear couch chic going on outfit
wise but the more I Swami's ice Tom the
more I grew to love it because it's
actually quite sleek and professional
after you get over the lake of the whole
cow texture
he's also one of the zodiacs that
inspires the most respect from me mainly
due to his interactions beyond the anime
story in the manga meas ice Tom is a
source of utter fascination capable of
holding an intellectual confrontation
with someone on Crocker's level and very
currently analyzing the likely results
of this accession wall he also has a
very intriguing hatsune on his cross
game which has to do with three colored
cards which have varying effects
combined with the limitations that he
has set himself so he's definitely on
the more interesting side of the zodiacs
number three though we have our current
chairman of the hunter Association
Cheadle Yorkshire who secured 312 votes
and while I'm much less of a fan of her
design than say me zeiss Don I do love
the character in general I think that
she doe represents some of the greatest
insight we received in the series that
was very thrilled when she became the
chairman just because it gives us a
different perspective in every way to
that of network and you can see that
most obviously in the changes that she
made to the hunter exam which now seems
to favor more psychological testing
rather than mass survival of death games
and she's also far more empathetic which
makes sense because she is a disease
hunter which can more accurately be
described as hunting for cures to
diseases so she's definitely who we want
during guide I know maybe a global
pandemic and she's also a triple star
hunter which is amazing given how rare
they are although all three known triple
star hunters are indeed members of the
zodiacs one of which is our second-place
contender parastone hill a one-time vice
chairman of the association and very
very briefly the actual chairman of the
hunter Association but he comes into
this with a pretty staggering 1215 votes
which is almost exactly 1/3 of the total
votes of the entire poll and who can
blame anyone for voting for this rat
Barristan is in my opinion one of if not
the most fascinating character that
Takashi has ever created and the only
negative thing I have to say about him
is that we simply have not seen more of
him every time he appears he just brings
more and more questions and intrigue but
he also has this terrifying or of
cruelty surrounding him that you can
never quite understand juxtaposed who is
overly nice outer shell but deep down
there is an extraordinary monster in
Paris ten Hill and one that I do look
forward to exploring one day although
that does come with great trepidation
and now let's conclude without obvious
number one position and the most favored
zodiac of the fans binging freaks we
received 1421 votes and once again yeah
it's hard to blame anybody for voting
for Jing because he comes equipped with
every weapon of intrigue the parastone
holds as well as the promise of being in
nan prodigy the likes of which we have
probably never seen in humanity and it
is always a pleasure to see Jing engage
in mental battles and his endless
fascination to explore the Dark
Continent is always appealing as well
firstly though I definitely would have
placed Jing below parastone and possibly
even below meas ice Tom because Jing
just doesn't quite pick my interests
like the other to do but he is one of
the most profound characters in Honda
Honda so this is not necessarily a
surprise and also I did very much expect
Jing and parse them to be number one and
two on this list that's just what
happens when you get an entire Rock
focusing on the two of them but I do
also feel like if I switch them out with
their replacements then well we would
have had a very similar situation occur
but for now congratulations to the
world's most questionable father Jing
freaks for being voted as the most
popular zodiac member in hunter hunter
and just to tack on to this conclusion I
actually found this process quite fun
and insightful it's great to know what
you guys are thinking and I want to try
doing a bit more of this so as a result
I have another poll up right now in the
community section of my channel asking
you to vote for your favorite member of
the Phantom troop which I think should
have some much closer results than an
examination of the zodiacs so please do
go and add your voice to that but what
do you guys think please do leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
join my discord server and if you'd like
to see more hunt hunter content then
please do go and check out some of my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for regular hunt onto glory to
live it straight into your YouTube feed
but for now this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next time